. This is really funny just because of the
the hypocrisy in it.
There's a guy who donated more than two million
dollars to that completely bogus true the
vote campaign to try to take the election
back from Joe Biden, despite the fact that
Joe Biden won.
And now one of these guys wants his money
back and says he's essentially been scammed.
I'm talking about right wing rich dude, Fred
Eshelman.
Fred Eshelman was convinced after the presidential
election that something wasn't right with
the results.
And so he decided to donate a bunch of money
to true the vote.
He called the group and said, I'm in for two
million dollars.
And over the next couple of weeks that followed,
Eshleman came to regret the donation, realized
that all of these conspiracy theories about
rampant illegal voting deserved to be doubted.
Yes.
Yes, they did.
And now he wants his money back.
And Trump's campaign and the Republican Party
in total collected more than a quarter billion
dollars.
That's two hundred and fifty five million
dollars in two months.
They said the money would go to legal challenges.
They said the money would go to recounts and
so on and so forth.
Very little of the money did 76 million that
Trump raised for Georgia and for reversing
the results of the election didn't go to that.
Instead, it went to paying off Donald Trump's
campaign debts.
And now at least some of these individuals
are saying, we got scammed and we want our
money back.
Now, Eshelman has filed two lawsuits and one
one in federal court has since been withdrawn.
The other is still going on in Texas state
court.
And he is alleging they didn't spend the money
on the things they were going to spend the
money on.
And I want the money back.
And at this point, you know, there's a couple
different things that I think are relevant
to talk about here.
First of all, with these types of things,
one should never invest more than they are
willing to lose.
I mean, it's not different than cryptocurrency
in a sense.
I've talked about I've held Bitcoin for four
years at this point, and I consider it speculative.
I consider it part of a small portion of my
assets that I am putting in what I know to
be risky assets.
And if it ends up being worth zero, if I get
nothing from it, that's sort of part of the
game.
Anybody who, quote, invested.
And I think that that's absolutely the wrong
term.
Who invested money in this true.
The vote campaign.
You should have gone in knowing this may go
to nothing.
I am not going in assuming or expecting that
there are going to be tangible results here.
Clearly, Fred Eshelman didn't do that because
he was bamboozled by the conspiracy theory.
So he was played by Trump and many of these
people were played by Trump.
Now, in terms of whether they deserved to
get their money back.
If you.
Actually believed that this was anything short
of a grift, then you clearly were not paying
attention.
And I do believe that some people like Fred
Eshelman may not necessarily have thought
that it was a scam, but they certainly might
have felt that I'm a rich dude.
If I throw enough money at a problem, something
good is going to happen, because that's how
a lot of these rich people operate in the
United States.
It's just a matter of throwing enough money
at it.
And I can get whatever I want.
OK, maybe some of these claims are exaggerated,
but if I give two million bucks, two and a
half million people cough up two hundred and
fifty million dollars, if you throw enough
money at a problem, we're going to get the
outcome that we want because that's how a
lot of these folks now have been conditioned.
But in terms of getting the money back, a
lot of these same people now alleging a scam
and saying, I'm filing suit and bah bah bah
bah.
They're the ones who say we can't have a nanny
state government.
We can't have a nanny state government protecting
people from themselves.
If people want to smoke, they should be allowed
to smoke.
People want one hundred and twenty eight ounce
sodas.
They should be allowed to have them and it
shouldn't be priced a different way or banned
or whatever the case may be.
And now they are saying something different.
Shouldn't by that same very same logic they
be allowed.
To donate money wherever they want, and then
the outcome is the outcome, caveat emptor,
buyer beware.
No, now they have a different approach and
I don't know ultimately what's going to happen
in court.
But it is amazing that, you know, there there
might be this idea that the only people Trump
was able to bamboozle were lower middle class,
uneducated rural folks.
No, no, no.
That's very wrong.
Trump also bamboozled a rich upper class folks.
And we should never understate the ability
of a grifter to grift lots of different people.
We'll have more coverage of this on the show's
Instagram page.
You can find us on Instagram at David Pakman
show.
We have a lot coming up today, including some
really almost sad segments on Fox News last
night, which will get to a little bit later
today, The David Pakman
Show
at David Pakman Dotcom.